One last thing we're going to look at
is how to attach something to our character.
Because so often in games and cinematics,
a character might be wearing something
or picking something up, equipping something.
And this is essentially just a great thing
to know how to do.
So in the engine, we do this using sockets.
Now a socket is something that we add to the skeleton
and it's parented to a bone
and it just follows that bone wherever it goes.
We'll then add the asset
that we want to attach into our sequence.
We'll reference the socket inside the sequence
to attach the two together.
Now in the sequence, we're going to use
an attach track to do this attachment.
But you can also use things like blueprint logic
and events in the timeline to trigger those attachments.
So let's add a socket to our skeleton first
and then we can set that up in the sequence.
So to find a skeleton for a character,
I'm going to select the character
that we have in the level, press Control B
and that'll browse to the asset in your content browser.
If I was to open that up,
we can then use the animation sub-editor icon
at the top here to find the skeleton
that's connected to this character.
So if I select that,
this is now a skeleton that we're using
and we've got a skeleton tree
in the left hand side here.
So I'm going to select probably spine four
or spine five here, let's go with spine five.
I'll right click this and I will add a socket.
And if we select the socket here, oops,
you can see if I change our preview settings,
so character bones and tick sockets here,
you'll be able to see any sockets
that we have on our character.
So you can see we have one here,
there'll be like some sort of item attachment socket
and we've got the spine of five socket.
So if I right click and rename our socket,
we'll just call this backpack underscore socket
because we're going to be attaching a backpack
to our character.
Now, if we were to go back to our skeletal mesh
and have a look in our skeleton tree,
we should also see that socket there.
If I save this, we don't, which is interesting.
How about I close it and I open it again.
There we go, so it's just refreshed now.
So we can see our backpack socket here
connected to our spine of five.
So coming back to our sequence here,
we can now add our backpack
that we want to attach to the character
and we can set up the attach track.
I jump over to the content browser
and if I just search for backpack
and then click and hold the skeletal mesh version,
hover over the sequencer tab
and drop it into our sequencer window here,
that'll bring it in.
If I just minimize money to make this a bit clearer.
To add an attach track,
just over the items that you want to attach,
hit the plus on the right hand side here,
hover over attach and choose the asset
that you want to attach it to.
So if the asset that you want to attach it to
is inside your sequence already,
you can choose it from this existing binding heading.
But if it's something that's in the level
that's not in the sequence,
you could go to new binding
and choose that from your outline here.
But we want to attach it to money,
so we'll just click that.
And we can see here,
we've got a handful of sockets
and all the joints of our character
that we're able to attach this to.
But we're just gonna choose backpack socket
because that's the one we set up to attach.
Now, you can see here
that it has attached to our character
and it's jumped up onto that socket.
So as we scrub through and play,
it's following our character around.
But it doesn't look quite right.
So it's halfway inside our character.
Now we could correct this one of two ways.
We could select the backpack
and then come to frame zero here,
set a key on the transform track
and just move it out
and reposition it to however we want the asset to look.
But if this is something you're doing,
you know, several times,
then you don't really want
to have to do this step every time.
Or if you're doing it in blueprints with an event,
you don't want to have to set up any extra logic there.
So we can actually change the default location
of our backpack socket to account for this.
So if we jump back to our skeleton socket here,
we can see that we've got our socket selected
and we can add a preview mesh to this.
So we can see what a mesh might look like
when it gets attached to the socket.
So if I right click the socket
and choose add preview asset,
I can then search for backpack
and that'll allow us to add it to,
as a preview mesh to see what it looks like
when it's attaching.
Now, because we're using SKM Manny
as our preview inside the sequence,
I'm actually gonna change our preview mesh here
to match SKM Manny
because his mesh is quite different from Quinn's mesh.
And we want to know that we're working
with the right mesh here.
So if I select the backpack socket
and just bring that out and reposition it
to where we think the backpack looks good,
I think that'll probably work for now.
Straighten up a bit more.
Once we come back out to,
if I save that actually first,
once we come back out to our sequence,
we can see now that we kind of have a double offset
because we have this transform track
working at the same time.
But we can see that there's definitely been a change
and has been an update to the location of this backpack.
So with the backpack selected
and the anim details here,
I'm just gonna hit this arrow, whoops,
to reset the property to the default values,
which is just zero.
And as you can see,
it will snap back to the location
that the socket's now in by default.
So if I set a key just where we are now
and delete that original key and drag this back to zero,
you can see that when a character moves,
our backpack is now attached to them
in the correct location.
And anytime that we attach this backpack,
whether it's in blueprint or whether it's in sequencer,
we know confidently that it's gonna snap to the right
place without us having to add any more transform offsets
to that with like a transform track
or any transform values that might need to be added
after the attachment.
So there it is.
We've just seen how to create a new animation
using Control Rig inside Sequencer.
Also how to blend existing animations together
to create something new
and how to then save that animation asset
to use elsewhere in the project.
And also how you can then animate on top
of a preexisting animation non-destructively
using a layered control rig.
There's really so much more to learn about control rig
and how animations work in engine.
And we have several different courses
that go into great detail
about how to create your own control rig
and how to utilize all of the other animation tools
in the engine.
So if there's more you want to learn about control rig
and how to animate in the engine,
you should definitely go and check those out.
I just wanted to share this last slide
that has a couple of links that goes into
a bit more detail about root motion in the engine,
as well as a link for more detailed breakdown
about animation blueprints
and a link for any Blender add-ons
that exist for the Unreal Engine.
And just to wrap up,
we've learned about the different types of animations
in the engine.
And we now know how to import and export our characters
and animations to and from the engine.
We have an understanding of the differences
between skeletons and skeletal meshes,
and then a brief overview
of the different animation subeditors
and what you could use those for.
Then we actually created our own animation from scratch,
as well as learning how to blend animations together
to create new animations
and how to attach these props to your characters
using sockets.
So thank you very much for listening
and remember to check out any of our other courses
if you want to continue developing
and best of luck with your animations in the future.